- It's very bright.
We like to keep it bright.
I love this, it's so rock and roll.
- Thank you. Look at the shoes.
- With the shoes! I know!
- 'Cause I am two feet tall.
- Okay, I am 5'3 and a
half. I'm not that tall.
- You're way taller than me.
- Wait, how tall are you really?
- 5'2.
- Okay, okay. Yeah.
But I do cheat, I cheat.
- I haven't seen you in a million years.
- I know.
So, we've always, I've
run into you a few times.
I know you know Robert, but I,
we've never had you on the show yet.
- I can't believe it.
- I know, I'm excited you're here.
- I was like, "How many
seasons have you done?"
And they were saying-
- This is four.
- Four!
- I know.
- Four seasons! (claps)
(audience applauding)
- Time flies.
Time flies, I know.
I mentioned the things that you do
whenever I introduce
you, but I left one out.
I heard that you are a
pickleball club owner.
- Yes, I do own a pickleball club. Yes.
- I've never played.
- Me neither. (laughs)
- What?
Wait, you never played?
- No.
- [Kelly] I figured you could teach me.
- No. I play paddle tennis,
so I do a tennis sport.
- What, do you mean ping pong or-
- [Eva] No, paddle tennis is-
- Not normal tennis?
- No, it's like in a smaller
court and it has glass walls.
It's not racquetball.
- Okay, I was gonna say racquetball.
- [Eva] It's not tennis.
And it's not pickle.
- It's a lot of sports in there.
Yeah, that we mentioned.
- I know, I know.
- I've never played either.
I've heard it's really fun though.
- It is super fun.
Yeah. And pickleball's super
fun from what I gather.
(laughs) I like watching it, I watch it.
Those players are crazy good.
- Okay, so these are
like, you go and watch
because it's not like a beginner's thing.
- No, no, these are
professional pickleball players.
Yeah, yeah.
It's not like I own a
league down in Santa Monica.
No, this is like a professional
league, it just started.
- Okay, okay.
- It's a big thing.
Anybody play pickleball?
- I wanna try.
I've never tried.
Everybody talks about it.
- We should try. You and I should try!
- We should do it next time.
Okay, we are both from Texas.
- I know!
- Do you miss it?
- I do.
- I miss the TexMex. That's what I miss.
- I miss the TexMex.
But I'm moving home, I'm
moving back to San Antonio.
- Oh, you are?
Oh, I love San Antonio.
- But you're from Fort Worth?
- I'm from Fort Worth, yeah.
- You're from the north.
- Yes, it is different.
- I'm from the south.
- But I love San Antonio.
It's a great city.
They did such a great job,
just, it's an easy city to walk around.
Like I don't see a lot of places in Texas,
it's a driving place, okay?
But in San Antonio, I feel
like I can walk everywhere.
It's like Austin.
- You can walk a lot of places.
It's also, I mean, the best
TexMex is in San Antonio
and South, but-
- Or in Fort Worth, whatever.
- No, no. I don't know, Kelly.
- Even he's like, "No,
and he's Texan." (laughs)
- Thank you. I'm a Texican, so I know.
- I'm a Texican.
(both laughing)
I love it.
I just love the runny queso.
That's what people don't get.
It's the melted queso.
The melted cheese versus the runny queso.
I have no time for any
queso that's not runny.
- I know. A lot of cheese in TexMex.
'Cause now I live part-time
in Mexico City now.
- Oh, I love Mexico as well.
- Yeah, Mexico City.
And the food is obviously very different.
And my husband's Mexican and I'm Texican,
so we fight all the time.
Like he's like, "That's so much cheese."
I'm like, "Yes."
- Exactly. Join me, won't you?
It's like, it's so good.
- Hence the reason it's so good.
- No, I do like authentic
Mexican food too.
- It's amazing, the
diversity in Mexico food.
- So you're there often?
You're in Mexico often?
- Yeah, like half the time.
We're half Mexico City, half Los Angeles.
- That's awesome.
- And now we're gonna be
Mexico City, San Antonio.
- Very cool. That's a quick trip.
So what's your favorite thing about
being there in Mexico City?
What's your favorite thing?
- Mexico City?
Oh, every, the food.
I mean, my life is about food. (laughs)
- I have no problem with this.
- My life centers around
food and yeah, the culture.
A lot of museums and the
culture's really celebrated there.
Like, you land and you
go, "Yep. I'm immersed."
- Shopping there is fun.
I love everything about-
- Restaurant, chefs,
music, theater, all of it.
It's just a really beautiful country.
- Very, very cool.
So wait, and you're now part
of Spanish nobility, right?
So this is, is it Dama Longoria now?
- I am Dama Lady Longoria.
- Dama Lady Longoria.
I will introduce you as such from now on.
- You must curtesy.
- What does this mean?
- You got to curtesy as you do it.
It's like, you know, one
of the highest honors
you get from Spain, this is from Spain.
So my family originally is from Spain.
- [Kelly] Oh, right on.
- And so-
- So is this to do with your ancestors?
- Yes, with my ancestors.
- Oh, very cool.
And so there's like Cavaleiros and Damas
and so now I'm Dama Longoria.
- That's so cool.
Do you get into that,
like about ancestry and stuff like that?
- [Eva] Yes!
- My mother got really into it
and I was like, "You're
a little weird about it."
And then I got weird about it.
I think it's cool too.
- Have you done the DNA thing?
- Well, I did it before,
'cause I don't know why,
but like many reasons I won't say on TV,
but I ended up,
because we're all getting
swabbed all the time,
so I was like, "Whatever."
So I did the 23 and me, all the ancestry.
I found all this stuff, it was cool.
- Yeah, I mean it's great
for health indicators.
- [Kelly] Exactly, yeah.
- If you're predisposed to
Alzheimer's or dementia,
like it's good for that stuff.
- It's interesting, though,
that your sibling is different from you.
Like that different from you,
like pulling from a different
percentage from a parent.
- Yeah, it's like they get more of a gene
than you get, yeah.
I'm basically adopted, so...
(Kelly laughing)
- You're like, "So..."
- I'm the youngest of four girls
and I look nothing like
my brothers and sisters.
And I mean, I have no brothers.
What am I talking about?
- So you don't look like them.
I don't look like them, either.
(both laughing)
You got four girls in
the house? That's a lot.
- Four girls, one bathroom.
- Oh my God. (laughs)
- My poor dad.
- That was like me on that,
the only intel I have on that
is whenever I was on "American Idol,"
they had us live in a
house like 20 years ago
and all the girls were just,
I'm just a very, I'm a tomboy.
And so I don't wear
makeup if I'm not working.
I don't do, I'm just not very girly.
So anyway, there, you know
it was like fighting for
hair and makeup time,
or bathrooms or whatever.
That's the only intel I have.
I was like, "Oh my gosh,
this gets hardcore."
Like, who gets in there first?
You know what I'm saying?
It was like, I was always happy to like,
not even make time for it.
But anyway.
So, your son is now four
and I hear he corrects you
when you're speaking Spanish.
Is this true?
- Oh, yeah.
- [Kelly] He's four.
- Yeah, he's four.
He's fluent, 'cause he's, his
first language is Spanish.
I didn't grow up speaking Spanish.
But because we live in Mexico City,
I was just shooting in
Spain, he's super fluent
and he corrects me all the time.
And he does it with like attitude.
- [Kelly] He's like disgusted?
- He's like, "Oh my God, Mom."
I'm like, "What? You're four."
Easy, easy.
- I'm disappointed.
- Yes, so disappointed
in my Spanish. He is.
- It's way easier.
It's so cool that he is
learning at such a young age.
It's easier.
You know, dialect, all of that
is easier to pick up then.
So he sounds very wise for his age.
- He's super smart.
(both laughing)
- He's brilliant.
- He's brilliant, if I say so myself.
- So both of our mamas were teachers.
Were you a good student?
- I was a great student,
but I felt like I had to be,
and like my mom, she was like,
in the time, in the moment,
she was so annoying, 'cause she would like
go to the school for everything.
And she would go and ask my teacher,
"Why did she get a B? I
read this, feels like an A.
My daughter needs to be in that class
and she needs to be on this track."
And so to have a mom like that
advocate for you at school
is super life changing and
important, looking back now.
So God bless all the
teachers in the world.
So I ended up being a great
student because she made me.
- That's amazing.
- Were you a good student?
- My mom's so angry right
now at home. (laughs)
I was not a, I think the
only thing that kept me
in school was the arts.
Like I just, I love learning.
I'm like an avid learner.
I love reading, I love all that.
I just didn't like, I just think,
and especially having kids now,
people like to learn differently.
Like, you know, we learn
differently and it's very hard
for me to sit still in like a desk
and like I'm learning.
- Well, the fact we still
learn that way is weird.
- I know.
It's just, it was just very hard for me
for like that many hours
in a day to be like
"Worksheet, worksheet."
- It's hard for most kids.
Still.
And especially like,
technology has disrupted
so many industries.
Every industry, healthcare,
how we buy stuff.
I mean, everything.
But yet it hasn't quite disrupted
how we teach in the classroom.
It should have. It should.
- Which is interesting,
'cause you thought COVID
would've changed that a tiny bit,
just 'cause we all were
on Zoom, but anyway.
Glad that's not still happening.
So, let's talk about
your new movie though,
"Flamin' Hot."
What made you wanna direct this?
- Well, the story made its way to me,
it's a story about Richard Montanez,
who was a janitor who worked at Frito-Lay
and had a huge hand in helping launch
the number one snack in the world,
which is Flaming Hot Cheetos.
And it's such a beautiful, inspirational,
motivational story.
Like this guy had the hardest upbringing
and the hardest life,
he couldn't even read or write,
didn't really finish high school.
I mean, nothing.
And is super successful today,
because he had this drive
and ambition and discipline
and he had this insane belief in himself.
And so when I read his
story and I was like,
"This happened?"
And it's one of my favorite
snacks in the world.
- Says literally every human I know.
Everybody loves Flaming Hot, yeah.
- Everybody loves Flaming Hot.
The first time I ate a
regular bag of Cheetos,
I was like, "Oh, I got a bad bag."
- You were like disappointed.
- Yeah. I didn't know
there was regular Cheetos.
- They forgot the flavoring in this.
- They forgot the flavoring in this bag.
And they were like, "No,
that's how Cheetos taste.
You're eating the hot ones."
And I was like, "What?
There's normal ones?"
- It's wrong and rude.
- Why do they sell the normal ones?
- I love the heart of that story
and I love that like how
many people will connect to
this character of like
maybe you don't achieve
what society tells you you need
to achieve to be successful,
but you still have it
in you to make waves.
- Especially for women,
when women are told like,
"Well, that job's not for
you," or a person of color,
like, "Oh, you know,
opportunities aren't for people like you."
- Yeah, love to hear it.
- He was like, he dared to
ask why not, why not me?
"Why can't I come up with something great?
I have a great idea.
Why can't I be heard?"
And I think a lot of
people are gonna identify
with that journey and that adversity.
We've all bumped up against it.
- I know that you've directed for years.
But is this your first like movie?
- It's my first movie.
- Okay, I was like,
'cause you've been doing
it for like a decade.
For shows, right?
- 10 years in TV, yeah.
- That's awesome to make that that jump,
'cause it's a lot, I love this.
- We ate a lot of Cheetos.
- You do like food. (laughs)
So, in the film, the main
character has a side hustle
as a kid, selling burritos.
So, did you have a side hustle as a kid?
- Oh, yeah. I had a lot of side hustles.
I had so many side hustles.
The main side hustle, I was like eight
and I would mow lawns.
Did you mow lawns?
- Yes, I mowed lawns.
- My dad was like, "I'll give
you $20 to mow the lawn."
So I did that like Sunday and I go,
"Okay, so if I mow it Monday,
Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday,
I'll have a hundred dollars on Friday,
my dad's like, "Not my lawn.
You're not gonna mow our lawn."
- It has to grow back.
- It has to grow.
And I was like, "Oh, I
just wanted to mow ours."
So then I would ask all the neighbors
if I could mow their lawns.
- That's smart.
I think it's so awesome when kids,
my kids are six and eight
and they still are like,
"How can I earn money?"
And I'm like, "Okay."
I like instilling that.
And even that, I make
them like, they're like,
"I want a toy."
And I'm like, "Cool, I've given you a lot,
so you can buy your own,
if you wanna go to Target right now."
And they'll use their own money.
And then they're like, "Wait, so wait,
I don't want that toy."
It just teaches them like money
management at a young age.
- Yeah, they said one of
the greatest indicators of
a successful adult is
not Ivy League schools
or if they went to Harvard,
it's did they have chores
when they were a kid?
Did they understand I have to do this,
and the responsibility of
doing something, and so...
- Wow, my mom did really well then,
'cause I had-
- I had so many chores.
Oh my God.
- I was the only kid in the
house, so I had all of them.
- Oh, you did?
I had a lot of chores too.
- That's good, though.
It teaches you responsibility.
And I always tell my kids too, I'm like,
"You are getting paid.
I'm paying for the roof of your head."
- Oh, God. You became your mom!
- I am.
I'm okay with it, yeah.
I came out all right,
so this should be fine.
Well, it's debatable, but what do you hope
people take away from the
movie, like the message?
- You know, I hope they leave,
I love, everybody who's
seen the film feels so good
when they leave.
You feel so good.
And I feel like we don't
have those movies anymore.
Like I love all the Marvel
and all that stuff too,
but like-
- I know, and I like
the big epic dramas too,
but I don't wanna be
like super sad either.
I wanna feel good.
- I wanna feel good when I watch a movie
and I wanna learn something.
And I think people leave are
gonna leave watching this film
with like, "What can I do?"
- That's, I think that people
are gonna leave this film,
going dreaming.
- [Eva] Dreaming.
- Yeah, and I think that's really cool.
- And that's, you know, a really big task.
And I think we accomplished it, yeah.
- [Kelly] Keep dreaming.
- Keep dreaming.
- There's no age limit there.